embalming students have to understand
the importance that every face is
different Morgan Freeman square face
Abraham Lincoln oblong face Kanye West
oval face my name is James Edward Smith
jr. I'm an instructor and clinical
director at Dallas Institute a funeral
service and I currently instruct
restorative art restorative art class
provides a skill set to be able to take
a deceased person who has experienced
trauma to the head and/or face and
restore those features in that phase so
that the family may have an option for
an open casket viewing or visitation in
a fifth quarter the students are tasked
with reproducing a sculpture of a person
that they choose and the anatomy has to
be accurate students generally picked
celebrities you know they're popular
faces and students tend to want to try
to recreate those from our restorative
art project I did Jennifer Aniston Jack
white
Viola Davis Frieda Calif i decided to do
David Lynch taking on the assignment
requires each of the students to
understand the proportions for the
features of the face here in school
because it translates to what may happen
in the actual preparation room
it is an acquired skill the more you
practice the more proficient the better
you're going to become the expectation
of the family is that this is something
we can sometimes do right away but we
have to take into account the amount of
trauma that the face has sustained we
need to have as much care when handling
the deceased as if they were in the
hospital under the care of a doctor
[Music]
I am very passionate about restorative
art because I believe it's important for
people to have the best memory picture
possible when it's time to say goodbye
we're task as embalmers to help families
have the option no matter the cause of
death to say goodbye to mom or dad or
brother or sister
you